the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so let's start with with a simple but
quite illustrative example so suppose
you're a bookie and what bookie does he
accept bet on on on the horses sets the
odds and then pays money back
probably collects a fee somewhere in
between so suppose it is a good bookie
and he knows quite well the horses and
there are two horses one horse has he
knows that for sure one horse has twenty
percent chance of winning in another
horses eighty percent chance of winning
obviously general public doesn't have
all these information so they place a
bet slightly differently and at the end
there is ten thousand bet on one horse
and fifty thousand bet on the another
horse
well bookie is sure that he possesses
good information so he suppose he sets
the odds according to the real real-life
probabilities so he says at four to one
what would be possible outcomes of the
race for him monetary so suppose the
first horse wins then what happens he he
has to pay back ten thousand then four
times more so he pays out fifty thousand
and he received 60 right so he can keep
ten thousand out of it okay so what
happens is there are the other more
probable horse wins
well he'll you have to pay back the
fifty thousand and one quarter of it
which is twelve and twelve twenty five
so at the end he'll pay sixty two and a
half thousand while he collected 67
right so he will in this situation he'll
lose
$2,500 well all in all he expects to
make nothing so he probably could
collect enough fees to cover his
potential loss but there is certainly a
very variable
in outcomes he can win a lot he can lose
some now
what if he forgets about his knowledge
about the real real life probabilities
of horses winning or losing and instead
set the bet according to to the amount
which were already bet according to the
market effectively so what if he sets
the better the odds five to one
according to the bets placed well in
this situation is the first horse wins
he pays back ten plus five times ten so
sixty he is zero and if the second horse
wins he pays back fifty plus one-fifth
of fifty plus another ten again 60 so no
matter which were horse wins he will get
zero with hunger potential and if he
collects collects some fee on top of it
he will make a riskless profit and
that's how actually bookies are
operating so it's a simple example but
it gives us a first idea how risk
neutral framework and risk-neutral
pricing when works so we are here not in
the business of making bets on horses
we're actually in the business of
pricing derivatives so we will talk
about the simplest possible derivatives
mostly derivatives on stocks but there
there are more complicated derivatives
which underline for which could be
interest rates bond swaps commodities
whatever so derivative contract is some
in general a general speaking a formal
payout connected to underline usually
the underlying is a liquid instrument
which is traded traded on exchanges and
derivative may be traded on exchanges
actually quite a few equity options are
trade exchanges but in general they're
over-the-counter over-the-counter
contracts where two counterparties just
agree on some kind of payout
one of the simpler derivatives is is a
forward contract so what is a forward
contract for a contract is a contract
where one party agrees to buy an asset
from another party for a price which is
agreed today usually the this contract
has this forward price is is set in such
a way that right now no money changes
hands right so and here here is an
example well suppose there is a stock
which right now is priced at 80 and this
is the forward for two years so somebody
agrees to buy this stock in two years
for this price and not surprisingly I
somehow set this price such that
currently the value the value of the
contract is zero and we'll see how I'll
come up with a price so this blue line
is actually payout what will happen at
the end right the the payout depending
the graph of F at time T to
determination time or expiry how it
depends on the stock price right so
obviously the payout is s minus K where
as as as as the stock price so it's a
linear function it turns out that the
current price is also really no function
but slightly shifted and we'll see how
how come it slightly shifted and how
much it should be shifted and K is
usually referred as a strike price
another slightly more complicated
contract is called
a call option so if previously the
forward is is is an obligation to buy
the asset for for an agreed price call
option is actually an option to buy to
buy an asset at the agreed price today
you can view it a call option can be
viewed as kind of insurance that the
against the asset going down basically
the payout is always pose
you can never lose money on the forward
you can lose money you agree on the
price see the asset ends up being lower
than this price but you still have to
buy it right here if if the asset ends
up at expiry below strike price or out
of the money then the payout will be
zero if on the other hand it it ends up
being above a strike price or it is
called
the option is in the money then your the
payout will be s minus K as before so in
mathematical terms the the payout is
maximum of s minus K and zero right and
that's what happens at time of at expiry
time this blue line so what is the price
of this option now well obviously it it
should be slightly both because even if
the if even if now the the asset is
slightly out of the money below strike
price there is some volatility to it and
there is a probability that we will
still end up in the money at expiry so
you you would be willing you should be
willing to pay something for this
obviously if it's way out of the money
it should be zero right on the other
hand if it's way in the money in fact it
should be just as forward and in fact it
is we will we'll see because if they
were the probability for the for the
asset going back to the strike price and
below will be low and that the black
Scholes equation is black Scholes
formula is exactly the solution for this
correct line which we'll see in a second
another simple contract which is kind of
dual to call option is a put option so
put option on the contrary is a bet on
on the asset going down rather than up
right so the payout is maximum of K
minus s and 0 so it's it's kind of
reversed also a ramp function at the at
maturity
and here here is the current price again
even if it's in the money if it's way in
the money you expect it to be to be zero
if it's way in the money we expect it to
be slightly below below forward just
because of discounting okay so and here
here are a few three main points which
we which will try to fall through the
class so first of all what we'll see
that if we we have current price of the
underlying and some assumptions on the
on how the the market or the the
underlying behaves there is actually no
uncertainty in the price of the option
obviously if we if we fix the payout
right so somehow there is no uncertainty
it's completely deterministic once once
we have once we know the price of
underline the other
interesting fact which we'll find out
it's actually risk neutrality meaning
that in fact the price of the option has
nothing to do with the with the risk
preferences of market participants or or
or counterparties it's actually only
depends on the dynamics of the stock
only depends on volatility of the stock
and finally the most important idea of
this class that mathematical apparatus
allows you to to figure out how much
this deterministic option price is now
so let's consider a very simple example
very simple market to period so suppose
our time is discrete and we are one step
before the maturity so right now our
stock has price as zero and there is
some derivative F zero
with some payout we will consider a few
of those right also will add to the mix
some a bit of cash right risk with cash
this some amount of risk with cash be
zero and risk less meaning that it grows
exponentially with some interest rate R
and there is no uncertainty it's
completely if you have now busy row we
know then in time DT our B 0 will be 0
will will will grow exponentially it
will become B e to the RT so a bond
basically zero coupon one a money market
account rather is its if you go to
Cambridge Savings Bank put $1 in today
then in a year you'll get $1 and
basically nothing because interest rates
are zero so in in time DT we will assume
with some probability P our market can
go to the state where stock becomes s1
the price of stock becomes s1 our bond
grows exponentially not no uncertainty
and our derivative becomes f1 or with
probability 1 minus P only two states so
our stock becomes s2 bond stays the same
and the the derivative is some f2 so
let's start with with our simple
contract the forward contract so one can
naively approach this problem trying to
get the price of of the derivative using
the real-world probabilities P and minus
P 1 minus P right so we know that the
payout is s minus K that's that's given
so one would say that if we we know we
are one step before the payout so let's
just compute expected value of the
payout using real real-world
probabilities get this this value and
actually what we are looking here is to
set K such that the price now at time
and T is zero that's usual convention so
will then set cake to do this to this
probability to do this to this number
which depends on real-world probability
and obviously depends on the stock price
at expiry so but obviously we don't know
real-world probabilities we can guess we
can say audits the stock is as likely to
go up then then down then then it's just
an average of n n stock prices or
something else but it's all hand wavy
and actually we never will be red
instead of doing this we're kind of
following bookie example let's try to do
something else let's think a little bit
so we have a stock which is trading it
at market now for the price as zero how
about we go to the bank and borrow as
zero dollars right now and immediately
go to the market and buy the stock so
right now we are not net zero we
borrowed as zero we paid it immediately
to buy the stock so we have stock at
hand then we'll wait for one period and
and at the same time sorry we are we
short we enter on the short side of the
forward contract so we agree to sell the
stock for for some price k zero so in DT
in one period of time the the contrary
expires we already have stock so we just
go and exchange it for k 0 k zero
dollars right but we at the same time we
need to repay our loan which now have
become as zero times e to the R DT this
is deterministic right we borrowed a
zero in time DT it became s times e to
the R DT so what what's our net then
that is K 0 minus s to the S
times e R DT so suppose K 0 is greater
than than this value then we made
riskless profit that there is no risk in
the in this in the strategy which we
which we proposed so this is good but
why wouldn't everybody do it all day
long on the other hand if K 0 is less
than s 0 that's that's that's a loss for
sure and if anybody thinks as we did and
we assume that everybody can do it and
nobody would would want to enter it
which means that in order for for our
forward to pry it to be price 0 now the
price the strike price has to be equal
to 2 to this amount and there is no
uncertainty about it so let's stop and
think a little bit
well actually just just to see just to
see how it works and that's that's
exactly why why why I set this this gate
to this number so by the way who can
tell me what which interest rate does it
doesn't imply
if our strike is our stock prices 80 our
strike is eighty eight point four to one
and and the expires in two years
approximately two point five so in two
years it will be five percent so roughly
speaking without compounding it should
be five percent of eighty plus five
percent it would be eighty four so ten
percent for two years so the interest
rate is five five percent yet so yet
it's actually exactly five with least
compatible exponential component yeah
well so good world probably five years
ago that's how it would work the two
years interest rates now the last time I
checked was I think 30 bits we can check
where where is the bond is trading now
give me a sec
yep 32 and a half basis points 1 11.6
basis points up since the morning quite
a bit by the way so yeah so right now
interest rates are basically zero so
these two these two lines would be very
close right now in for two years in any
case so coming back to our to our
example so what's what's important here
how did we arrive to to to the stripe
resort to this price of the forward
contract we in fact tried
we took some some amount of stock in
this particular case it will be the
words the whole price of stock
we took some amount of cash and by
combining these two pieces we somehow
replicated the final payoff right and
that's the general idea of risk-neutral
pricing pricing and replicating
portfolio what we will try to do in the
rest of the class is for take a payoff
and try to find a replicating portfolio
may be more complicated maybe than a
dynamic dynamic such that at the end
this replicating portfolio will be
exactly our payoff right and what would
it mean obviously it would mean that the
current the the current price of the
derivative should be the price of our
replicating portfolio right now right
and that's how the the risk-neutral
pricing works so we are still in this
simple situation but we will try to
price a general pay payoff f1 a general
payoff F right and here I how how it
goes so we still will try to form our
replicating portfolio out of the bond of
some amount of bond and some amount of
stock and we will say that will we will
need a s1 and B of the bond right and we
try to we'll try to find a and B
that no matter what the real-world
probability is we at maturity at one
step maturity will replicate our payoff
exactly unfortunately in this particular
case that's very doable is just two
equations with two variables we should
be able to do it and we can solve it and
find this a and B then we'll substitute
them in this formula right take the
current price of the stock which we know
and and some cash and find the current
price current price of the derivative
right and this work this should work for
any derivatives it doesn't matter is it
forward call put or some complicated
complicated option as long as it's
deterministic at expiry an interesting
way to look at it is to rewrite this
formula slightly in such a way which
does remind us taking a an expected
value may be discounting it because this
is expected value sometime in the future
but this probability and it is a
probability because this number Q here
is between 0 and 1 but this probability
has little to do with with real real
real world right in fact it's something
different but such probabilities exists
and it's called the measure where our
stock behaves like this is called a
risk-neutral measure or martingale mere
measure and in these measures will see
the the value of all the derivative will
be just expected value of our appeal and
that's yeah that's what what I'm trying
to say here
now so now let's get into continuous
world right in continuous world we will
need some assumptions on the dynamics of
our stock underline and let's make an
assumption that it is law it it is log
normal what it what does it mean that
it's look more normal it means that the
proportional change of the stock over
infants infinitely small amount of time
DT has some drift mu and some stochastic
component which is just Brownian motion
right so this DW is distributed normally
with mean zero and start the deviation
which is actually square root of DT
that's how broadly emotion works and
that's extremely important that the
standard deviation of going Brownian
motion is square root of delta T and
that's how it works so and again we will
use this idea of replicating portfolio
what would it mean in this in this case
well we will we would like to find such
coefficients a and B on this infinitely
small period of time DT such that by
combining small changes in stock with
coefficient a and small changes in in
bond with with coefficient B will
exactly replicate the change in the
derivative in the payout of derivative
in indeed not PL in the derivative in
the change of the derivative over this
infinitely small time T well to do this
we will need to use it as formula did
you talk about either already ok cool
that's great
so just to remind you that it is formula
is nothing more than the Taylor rule
the first approximation up to DT but
because of of the standard deviation of
the Brownian motion being on on the
scale of square root of T we will need
one more term right so one one term is
DF DT by DT another is DF by D as well
yes but and the square of GS now is is
actually of order of magnitude of DT so
we'll need a quadratic term there all
right so if this is our DF so what we'll
do we'll differentiate we will just
substitute it here right we'll
substitute it here we'll substitute DF
taken from it as our D s each which is
like this N and G B and D B is let's not
forget that DB that B is deterministic
right there is nothing uncertain about
it so DB is actual RB DT right because
our B grows exponentially with interest
rate R so we substitute everything into
the formula above this is just our DF
with D as expanded and everything and
then we start compare comparing the
terms one immediate thing to notice that
a has to be equal to G of D F for over D
s for this for this to hold right and if
we compare the the terms you know DT
will get this expression here but that's
actually even more the most important
part then we'll we'll go and use the our
knowledge that that some part of our
equation is deterministic and basically
take F and a s on one side and leave the
deterministic part on the other side
differentiate differentiate it once once
again and left left side will be just RB
DT and if we substitute once again d DF
and don't forget that what we learned is
that a is equal to DF by D s then we
collect all the terms and arrive to this
to this partial differential equation
which which connects which basically is
a partial differential equation for the
current price of a derivative of any
derivative and how it if we solve it
then way we should should be able to to
know the price of the order derivative
so now how do we solve this this partial
differential equation well yeah so a few
observations about about this equation
well the the first observation is that
any tradable derivative we made no
assumptions about the payoff so so any
tradable derivative is any payoff should
satisfy this equation the other
observation is as we expected there is
no dependency on real-world drift or any
any probabilities of going up or down
the only dependence dependence is on the
volatility of the stock right not only
we we found the value of the derivative
so most importantly we actually we're
able to come up with with a hedging
strategy and what does it mean we came
up with a hedging strategy
well we found coefficients for any time
we found the coefficients a and B such
that we have a replicating portfolio so
instead what we could do at any point of
time we can hold the derivative the
short a show derivative and long the
portfolio of stock itself and some cash
and we know how much it should be
here it's more complicated we have to
dynamically change these numbers as time
develops every time DT we will have to
rebound but both both parts will
replicate each other perfectly
it's like in a bookies example we can go
go to a two counterparty I agree into
four for some derivative contract
probably with some fee and then we will
go to exchange and buy the stock and and
we will get just cash from the bank and
we'll maintain this at some amount of
talk and some amount of cash and we will
be sure that we are we are hedged there
is no risk in in this color combination
of the derivative and in our hedge so we
will just collect the fee on the
transaction so that's that's what
actually how the business is working we
traders are trading and hedging their
positions immediately I mean they do
take some market risks but you want to
take very very little and very
directional or very specific market risk
and not not everything so so the the our
strategy allows us to have a hedging
portfolio at the same time hedging
strategy another more mathematical but
practical consequence is that actually
by certain not very easy change of
variables we can take the black Scholes
equation and put it back to heat
equation actually it's I suggest it as
one of the topics for the final paper
for you to do it or check it out in the
books and go and understand it but the
good part of it that heat equation is
well known and well well understood
there there are many many ways to solve
it numerically for for simple payouts or
for calls and puts we don't have to do
it numerically but if the payout payoffs
are more complicated or the the dynamics
is is different then numerical methods
will be needed for
so again to solve this equation we'll
need as for any partial differential
equation we'll need some boundary and
initial conditions and these come from
our final payout fro of the option right
which we know we know what what happens
at expiry and some boundary conditions
for for call and put the final payout is
we know right
so at time T and the boundary conditions
which describe we discussed we can
observe them graphically so basically
for call as we said at current time T
and boundary 0 it should be 0 the price
should be 0 and at at infinity it should
be actually the forward price so it
should be just discounted discounted
discounted s minus K discounted payout
rate and similarly fought for put
so given this these conditions and we we
we can solve the equation and as I said
for for : put and for simple dynamics or
Blackshaw dynamic log normal dynamics
actually these this equations can be
solved exactly exactly
meaning up to up to disturb the normal
normal distribution which still has to
be computed numerically obviously but
here as a formulas they do kind of look
a little bit and we'll see well about it
that there is some kind of expected
value blowing on right one probability
times time times another but these are
the formulas and that's how I drew the
lines on the graphs and as I said in
fact the whole world instead of solving
the whole the whole partial differential
equation we can approach it from a risk
neutral risk neutral position and say
that in fact the price of our derivative
now is just as expected value of out pay
or payout discounted probably from from
the from the maturity but not in real
time a real-world matter but in some
specific risk-neutral measure and how
how do you find this risk-neutral
measure well the risk-neutral measure is
such that the drift of our stock is
actually interest rate its riskless
that's exactly how how we saw we saw it
we saw it in our binary example right so
even in our binary example the our
expected value of our stock under
risk-neutral measure meaning
using the risk-neutral probability was
was drifting with this interest rate are
so that the same happens in in
continuous case and that's another good
exercise and I would accept it as a
final paper is computing black Scholes
black Scholes driving the black Scholes
formula just by discount by taking
expected value of the Colin put payout
with is the distribution log normal
distribution terminal distribution
alright so for more complicated payoffs
the the the life becomes more
complicated and some finite differences
should be used for more complicated
payoffs or American payoffs or past the
penalty of three methods or Monte colors
in simulations and that's what was
happening in real life yeah
now since we have actually a point of
time I I would like to give an example
of how replicating idea of replicating
portfolio works I give a couple of more
examples so so okay here is a Bloomberg
screen for foreign options call options
on IBM stock it's actually was taking a
while ago a few years ago but for add so
here are different strikes for a call
option the the current price of the
stock is 81 point point 14 and here are
the strikes of of the call so obviously
if if the option is if the option is way
out of the money meaning the strike is
very high compared to to the stock price
they the value of the option is 0 if
it's way in the money in fact it is just
s minus K so s meaning of being 81 and
say the strike being 55 so it's 26 right
there is some difference but actually
here it's it's a bit small because the
difference should be judge discounting
as we know right but it's pretty short
dated options the options they they're
probably a month a month long so there
is not much discounting so it becomes
pretty pal it's similar here right so I
mean this changes by five these changes
by five it's pretty linear but it
becomes nonlinear around the money
around current stock price right so we
do observe this this behavior but to
tell the truth here if you were to I
didn't put the implied volatilities here
but that's actually you would observe
that the world is not black Scholes
meaning that what's the assumption of
black Scholes the assumption of black
Scholes is that every option for for any
strike on a given stock and I give an
expiry would have the same volatility
right so if we went through the size of
implying the volatility according to
black Scholes formula from from the
option price which is traded on the
market and an current price we would
find out that actually the the
volatility is not is not constant with
strike well it's actually skewed well
actually it's it is smile we would find
something like this which means that
black hole theory is not perfectly good
right so something more complicated is
should be done but in some cases we even
don't need to do something more
complicated one example being so-called
put-call parity right so let's see
suppose we look at the screen so we know
all prices for all Co options for all
strikes well probably some granularity
but we know those but instead of pricing
a code we need to price a put somehow we
don't know how I am except our stock
looks like so we have strong suspicions
it's not exactly log normal so there is
some volatility smile it's not
constantly the world is slightly not
black Scholes
so how how do we price put well let's
see
will stare long enough at the payouts of
the : put so what's the payout of of a
call with some strike it looks like this
right the payout of the put with the
same strike would look like this so what
if we take we buy a call and sell a put
so this would go like this right
straight line looks very much like
forward right so if we actually subtract
a stock from here move it from here then
it should be yep
- Kay yeah I think I think I do go to
science correct right and and this is
just a number right and that's what
happens at payout so if we take this
portfolio if we action now by call
seller put and sell stock we know that
at the end we'll for sure get the K in
money right so which means that now so
this this is at time T so right now it
looks to me that if we do write this and
that's just the current price of the
stock this should be
right we just need to discount this
price to two now this amount of cash
which means that our put at any time T
is stock minus K right so if we know all
the prices for any strike k if you know
if we know price of a call we don't need
any black Scholes or or anything we can
immediately tell everybody how how much
is either put right so this this
relationship is actually called Co put
parity and that's again that's that's a
replicating portfolio it's a
simplification possible it's static
meaning that we fix it now and we don't
change it till the till expire so it's
it's quite good this way
but that's that's how it works
another example so for this I have
actually a picture so again we have the
same situation we have prices of cold
but instead of pricing a call we want to
price digital so what is digital digital
is such a weird contract which payout is
just step function basically it's a bet
on on a stock to to finish above strike
price K right if if at expiry the stock
is above K you get one you get one
dollar if it's below you get nothing
zero right so so such an interesting
contract the question is can we price it
given that we know the the practice of
calls so an I suggest we we use the idea
of replicating portfolio any ideas
how to do it it's my typical typical
interview question we'll just pretend
that your interview yep
the culprit yeah you're absolutely good
you're you got enough yeah so here here
here how it goes so this is a a strike a
right so let's let's buy well buy a call
with strike K minus 1/2 and sell a call
with with strike K plus 1/2 right that's
we just sold so how the if we combine
these two well actually if it if this is
one yeah this is one it should look
something like this
right
so how will it look like so obviously
here it's zero right then it will be
like this right and after that it will
be what it will be constantly and
because this is key minus 1/2 and this
is K plus 1/2 it will be exactly 1 right
good
so our way payout at the end will be
like this so it's good but there is
quite a bit of slope here so how can we
do better than this well if we sell it
at K minus by that K minus 1/4 and and
sell that at K of plus 1/4 and combine
just combine those it will be exactly
the same but the the level will be 1/2
so we need to buy to buy two of those in
to sell two of those right well we might
as well go k minus epsilon and K plus
epsilon so it will be cold price at
strike K minus epsilon minus call price
at K plus epsilon divided by two epsilon
right this this to epsilon Confucian
needed to rescale back it they were
scared back to 2 1 right so in fact if
we go small apps and we need a lot of
box right well and that's how how that
that's that's the approximation of our
digital price and that's actually how
how people on the market do do price and
catch the most importantly the the
digital contracts because because Cole
Cole contracts are liquid and they are
traded on exchanges while digital's are
way less liquid so somebody would go
again
to counterparty enter into digital &
Hedges on the exchange this to cause
physical spread but now tell me is it
surprising that I mean how well what
does it remind you yeah so it's
derivative of the co price by with
respect to to strike right is it is it
surprising how did our Co price look
like it's a ramp right if we take a
derivative of this what what what vulgar
yeah so it's just so in fact if we do
something even more weird with this I
don't know take a square or or something
something else the same will apply right
so it's not surprising at all all right
so that's that's basically how how the
duplicate this idea of replicating
portfolios is is it extremely powerful
and in fact that's that's what happens
in in real life in real life you have
some complicated derivative which you
need to hedge and how to hedge you finds
something else which replicate the to
certain extent replicates your payoff
that's what you'll try to do and that
this will be your hedge portfolio
usually it's dynamic so you you'll have
to rebound and that's how you you
basically reduce the risks